we have a guest let's go for it that's
exactly why we do have yes
let me guess uh could it be a wonder
well you have him on the screen right
now yes sir so that's not a difficult
guess we do have a wonderland he's the
only one who's won his game
dominant victory in his game against
pedro espinoza wonder welcome back to
the show congratulations uh big victory
for you it seems like whenever you lose
a game then you come back with some
devastating revenge the next day is that
how you're feeling as well right i mean
sometimes you lose eight rating points
in one day get 0.8 back so a pretty fair
trade there um
yeah i mean
i thought today is
fine um i mean i think the game went
pretty smoothly and
wasn't really much to discuss there
let's uh look at the game because it did
seem like you mentioned that you broke
through quite early on um especially
after this
simplification in the center with taking
on d4 and you got that e5 breaking
is that when you felt like you're taking
over the initiative and the game yeah
i'm not too sure how the opening goes um
i had this against parham maxudu from
the black side and it was very similar
like i just wasn't that familiar with
the plans and i sort of set up in a
similar way he did and he just crushed
me with like d4 and and knight takes d4
i mean not the exact position but the
structure just like queen 2 rook d1 and
there was just no chance at all for me
yeah i don't know if e5 works at all i
mean i thought knight takes d4 was quite
fine as well but
yeah after e5 it looked
okay and knight 2594
and bishop g492 was a little important
but
i think knight that's why uh knight to
h7 was probably the only way to go for
him
i mean i think probably e5 is not the
best move because it does allow him some
chances like if he loses the exchange
then
um
i mean there's always
some compensation on the light scores so
right more or less acceptable for him
but the way the game went like after
takes on
after we simplified all this i mean
with knight takes e6 and so on
um yeah this should be
technically waiting for white and and i
think he didn't defend in the best way
but
um the conversion was quite smooth after
uh that i wonder congratulations um
important victory for you to try to get
back into the game still two rounds to
go who do you have uh next
um i think i finished with andrew hung
and balaji
um
yeah just looking to play two normal
games i think
um looks like christopher is really
running away with it again i think
i'm not too sure if i thought he was
winning again well speaking of that
let's take a look at that game maybe we
can pull that and uh
gauge your interest in that one
he's definitely not winning he's uh one
down right now
and uh a double pawn on the g file
that's
i don't know it looks pretty good for
black right yeah he's probably seen
better days in this tournament
yeah i i don't know i think um
yeah as i said earlier like basically i
just want to finish this tournament as
fast as possible
so
yeah i mean
today was good but yeah i hope that i
can keep it up i wonder congratulations
we'll see you tomorrow
good luck uh